hello reject nation I'm Greg Alba what
is your name dear I'm Lisa Lisa my
helices here with me today how are you
I'm great
how are you let's catch up on camera
yeah should I take these out stay a
while
guys Lisa mihalick has a YouTube channel
please go check it out as soon as you
can also follow her on Instagram where
she does modeling photos and her
boyfriend will get mad at you for all
the nasty comments you leave but it
entertains me so please do it right away
can you see your boyfriend's thing no I
don't know boyfriend I'm just trying to
transition him have this makes sense
right there was a proposal at the Emmys
did you guys hear about this yeah you
watch here I don't watch the Emmys I
didn't watch the Emmys this year I never
watched I heard there was a proposal and
I think this guy Glenn Weiss if I'm not
mistaken he won for outstanding
directing for a variety special and I
think that special was the Oscars I'm a
sucker for romantic publicity proposals
yeah someone proposes it like a baseball
stadium I'm like you son of a [ __ ]
that's freaking adorable
I like that and I know Lisa's waiting
for that ring waiting waiting
impatiently no let's watch this one too
thanks to my daughter Sydney and Taylor
I love you girls more than you will ever
know he needs to get marry I want to
thank Jen Todd Mike DeLuca
Oscar one thank Don Hudson John Bailey
everybody at the Academy and all of our
friends at ABC I'm really grateful to be
here but it's bittersweet the person
most proud at this moment would be my
mom and she passed away just two weeks
ago
oh my part of my heart is broken I don't
think it will ever be repaired but she's
in and she always will be
mom always believed in finding the
sunshine and things and she adored my
girlfriend Jan Jan you are the sunshine
in my life and mum was right don't ever
let go of your sunshine you wonder why I
don't like to call you my girlfriend
because I want to call you my wife I
love you and I just saw oh dude Emmy
history awkward walk 67 years ago my
sisters and brothers I didn't swipe at
dad knows I have it okay
[Applause]
I'll never be the ring that my mom
wanted your finger in front of all these
people and in front of my mom and your
parents watching from above will you
marry me
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
that could have gone really south really
big things like somehow you must know
Matt Dan talk about a double win right
there he wins the Emmy and then it's the
girl that's guys having I feel positive
grieving process I've ever seen over the
loss of my mom that hit me I knew there
was a proposal but I did not know like
all that you know mainly recommended and
I checked this out my girlfriend you
should do a reaction this right here on
YouTube why I don't know man like I
wondered that if I were to ever propose
privately
you know I might like it higher I might
do one of those things there are times
where I like I like to have very private
things - yeah like for my birthday I
didn't make a bunch of public posts and
stuff like that I'm like let me keep
this really low-key in private what I'm
doing I don't want to ever want to know
what's going on and I feel the same way
about my relationship today like I might
share some Instagram photos or whatever
but I'm not gonna go out there and just
share a bunch of videos and really
publicize my relationship I've like
changed in that department yeah but you
know if I knew I was gonna win and I
knew I'm like I want to get married I
would probably do with this guy he's
winning at life right now yeah yeah
would you want this kind of proposal
boyfriend you watching I also want what
he wants - I would want what he wants -
I you know they say like oh do what she
wants
now they say well if you put yourself in
that person's shoes you know what makes
them happy you know it'll be special for
them but I want it special for us it's
not just about me it's our moment you
know so you want a proposal a Pizza Hut
is what I gather from this job it's like
it would be an hour moment not just mine
so I would want what also makes him
happy that's nice the breadsticks he's
creative enough to to come up with that
amazing mm-hmm he knows he's amazing
better start pumping your chest man he
is perfect he's very beautiful you guys
do look like Tom Cruise and Cameron Diaz
at a night-and-day hey I should see them
together it's really nice but yeah back
to this guy for a second I don't watch
the Emmys but it reminds me of when I
was like turned off the Oscars before
la-la-land did not win this is not a
joke moonlight is won Best Picture and
then I hold our deal we're lala land won
but then it was actually moonlight now I
was like ah crap I turned off before the
great thing happened yeah and it's stuff
like this like maybe I should start
watching live events again because right
be able to catch something beautiful
like this for the first time or I could
do a reaction to it on YouTube this got
me misty-eyed oh man I mean can you
imagine all the emotions he's going
through in that moment like he's winning
yeah he's grieving his mother and he's
asking his girlfriend to be his wife
like that's a lot going on they're gonna
do some nice oh and I wanted to give a
page from the day shout-out to a man on
our patreon whose name I
reveal it here is a totally jumbled
haven't mentioned you in a while TJ but
you know this guy he's married had a kid
not long ago his wife bangin knows a lot
about comic books and he proposed to her
at a Wendy's
[Laughter]
but each my friend
yeah my guys the the fast-food
restaurant she thought she was throwing
out a pickle but really it was a ring oh
my she was humiliated because it's a
Wendy's who wants to get proposed to at
a Wendy's and the disguise of a pickle I
turned myself into a pickle she said no
and she actually thought she wanted to
have an abortion and no numbing up and
she almost did it but then ultimately
decided against it because teach has a
huge huge Oh God and you should be proud
of that buddy
teach anyway let's transition to an
outro yeah listen guys do you believe in
love yeah Oracle when were filming but
not for them when they're commenting
that's the way it works yeah you got
this down Lisa Malik yes I know that I
get it now awesome I'm really happy
about that we're worried guys you can
believe in love that's cool totally cool
do you believe that we can wrap this
video up
come on boys you can subscribe to the
reject nation where this is not exactly
movie related but it kind of is and you
could check us on patreon we got TV show
reactions and q and A's the whole blasty
blast over there Lisa my hellix youtube
channel it's a fantastic time and check
her out on Instagram where she
is posting really good photos of her
traveling the Los Angeles and Gabriel
Valley area yeah she's not confused by
that statement guys you take care of
yourselves and fall in love one day
trust me it's worth it and the hurt is
even better